il était de lutter contre la
consommation de tabac et la consommation
d'alcool était vraiment de faire baisser
les consommations qui à l'époque était
extrêmement élevé notamment sur le tabac
pouvoir que quand les les prémices de la
loi evin est peut-être la réflexion a
été a été monté ou pour d'autres ça on
avait des consommations de tabac ne
rende société française qui est bien
entre 45 et 50% de prévalence donc ont
aidés dans des situations qui était bien
différente de celle qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
aujourd'hui pour mémoire d un quart de
la population dans son ensemble humain à
l'époque on était quasiment la loi evin
a permis de considérer l'alcool et le
tabac comme des produits particuliers
qui avaient une dangerosité et qu'il ne
fallait pas traités comme des produits
de grande consommation habituelle
c'est grâce à la loi evin que le tabac
peut augmenter que le prix peut
augmenter de façon régulière
il a été sorti d'un indice des prix qui
permettait pour l'alcool et le tabac de
les faire évoluer plus facilement ses
expériences et un impact économique plus
large les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui
faut bien voir que c'est véritablement
l'eldorado publicitaire un des
industriels du tabac et de l'alcool
et aujourd'hui c'est un espace n'est pas
réglementée elle est très efficace et
elle va vers la cible prioritaire des
industriels ils sont justement les les
jeunes